griffin jacks takes the mound for the
minnesota twins you look at his record
the era up there because really of
just
one appearance he's been as dick
mentioned in the open door show
very good the last
three starts
that's strike three to the back stop
engel runs well garver throws well safe
at first though
[Applause]
half swing but he went
and abram has been scuffling a little
bit as of late
here's the 2-2 pitch breaking ball
strike three call the slider locking up
jimenez
so jack strikes out three white sox
don't score dallas kykel last time out
against kansas city was very good six
innings gave up three hits on for his
20-second start looking for his eighth
win his era just a touch below four and
a half
three walks in the first inning and
that'll bring a rise to the plate with
the bases loaded
when you're hitting fifth in a lineup
you get a lot of these opportunities and
you hit with runners in scoring position
bases loaded second and third
first and third a lot of opportunities
base hand right fail
ref schneider will score the twins have
to hold donaldson at third
and arise gets the first hit and drives
in the first run
[Music]
so arise rips a ground ball single
between abreu and hernandez ref snyder
is in donaldson to third garber advances
to second
on the 27th rbi for luisa rise
low fastball favorite ceno change up
favors kaiko
tapper toward third
and they'll get the out at first coming
in as donaldson and i think if monkatta
had looked toward home
the hobbled donaldson could have been
retired on a force play but the out has
made it first ceno driving in his 46th
run and it's two to nothing it's up to
adam engel hernandez led off the inning
with a base hit he's still at first with
two gone this is hit hard in the air to
center by adam engel with ref snyder
back it is gone
this game is tied on one swing
from adam engel
that's homer number seven he's driven in
18 and he has made himself
a power threat he got a fastball it was
right down the middle and he took it out
over the center field wall and just like
that it's a brand new game
1-1 abrayu hits one deep left center
gone
into the bullpen
they go back to back
and the socks lead three to two keep
talking about the long ball lynn it's
working out well
a gator arm that out of here fastball
tried to tie him up he yanked his hands
in and it was a short powerful compact
swing to nail this pitch
and on the outside edge another call
third strike mankata
is a strikeout victim
seven already a career high for jacks he
struck out six
in four innings against the white sox
back in july
this is his game right uh right there
throwing the ball on the corner of the
of the
strike zone on the edge of the strike
zone
exactly where it was you set up that
pitch strikeout number eight a pitcher's
willingness to come inside with good
fastballs up and in
just opens up the get the outside of the
plate so much it gets hitters in a hurry
run scoring ground out to third his
first time it's this one back up the
middle that is snared by hernandez and
the gold glover has a dandy to retire
sano
it starts with positioning and ends with
first step quickness
and cesar made a terrific play he was
playing him up the middle our t-mobile
coverage camp this is a cutter
and sono hits the daylights out of it
98.8
that's the exit velocity
which led to nothing after one arise
don't win a run and then a ground out
mcgill sono as
zuvala turn around and head back to the
dugout
so strikeout number nine
for the young griffin jacks
i think half of his hits her extra base
hits so on a foul tip hung on by garber
and there's 10 strikeouts for
griffin jacks here tonight he's going to
walk off the mound
twins trailing oh three to two
payoff pitch
his bounce left side monkana got rid of
it quickly hernandez is turning time for
two
five four three and kykel did get that
ground ball to the left side juan gets
rid of it quickly and the turn by
hernandez is just outstanding he is very
quick
on the pivot this ball is out over the
plate that'll get ostadio to the plate
with a man aboard
pasta deal with a couple of groundouts
down the line and deep ostadio
puts the twins in front
home run number six
for la tortuga
got a cutter didn't get didn't let it
get inside threw his hands in through
the big end of the bed
at the ball you had some nice extension
for an inside cutter like that and
flipped it right in the seats what a
what a nice swing and a nice at bat by
lotto dude
they can roll over on it again
another slatter and to para strikes out
ref snyder for the first out here in the
seventh this one bites at the very end
looks like a strike and then disappears
out of the zone and ref snyder no
contact colin sets up waiting on the one
two here it is and another strikeout for
topera
back-to-back punches both on the slider
and there's two down
anderson leads stays and the 2-2 pitch
line to third caught by ostendial throws
back to first double play dug out by
poor base running from anderson a line
drive to third a rocket but caught by
the turtle
he snagged it quickly fired across a low
throw but cino with a great dig on the
back end of that play
and the white sox do not score in the
eighth inning
last couple of years alexander coleman
was a pretty good closer for the white
sox they decided not to resign him they
backed up the truck and brought in liam
hendricks to be their closer the twins
signed column a
tapper short
charged by simmons
in time to get him on the way
chopper up the right side two hops right
to cenote away
[Music]
chopper to third arise in time
and the bullpen nearly perfect
to save the win for griffin jacks
boy it's hard to say enough about what a
good ball game this was what a good ball
game the twins played what a great six
innings that young man right there
griffin jacks had